okay so the trailer for The Last of Us
episode 3 is now out and throughout this
video we're gonna be breaking down the
new look so far the show has given us an
in-depth look at some of the characters
that we briefly got to meet in the game
and this extra development has really
helped the audience see who these people
are for example episode 1 had a whole
day in the life of Sarah and it seems
like episode 3 is gonna be fleshing out
way more than what we got in the source
material originally we met Bill and
Lincoln and it was only after moving
through the town and we discovered what
happened to Frank in this video we've
got a lot to talk about involving that
but big spoiler warning if you haven't
played the game and don't want to know
what happens if you enjoy the video
please hit the thumbs up button and
don't forget to subscribe a breakdowns
like this every day without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the video
[Music]
not today you knew World Order Jack boot
my name's Frank here's the thing Frank
if I feed you then every bum you talk to
about it is going to show up here
looking for a free lunch
and this is not an Arby's
well Harvest didn't have free lunch was
a restaurant
sooner or later there will be Raiders
it'll come at night quiet and armed
yeah
call Joel
we'll be fine
now the new look opens with bells sat in
front of some CCTV monitors in the game
you arrived in Lincoln to find a
completely abandoned by humanity and all
that was left was Bill who guarded over
the town he'd set up traps throughout it
and after saving you from one of them he
went to his home in the church he said
that there'd been a military Caravan
that had crashed in the town recently
and you made your way out to it and
ordered a steal a truck battery here you
found that it had already been taken and
with the infected swarming you you were
forced into a school after beating a
blowder you made it to the other side
and traveled through the neighborhood
which is when you came across Frank
turns out that he and Bill had been
lovers but after a while Frank got to
the point where he couldn't stand him
and thus he made a break for it when the
Caravan crashed unfortunately he got bit
along the way and he ended it all after
leaving pillar note saying how much he
hated him now you were able to use the
truck he'd hook the battery up to and
drive out to Pittsburgh which I'm
guessing it was where the episode's
gonna end and they'll be setting up
things for episode 4. this entry itself
seems to be detailing Bill's time in the
20 years after the outbreak happened and
also his relationship with Frank now on
the screens at builds watching we can
catch a group of people and also Federal
soldiers my guess is that the whole town
leaves and this is when Belkin set it up
as his home free from the control of
others love the old PC we can catch to
the right and this seems like it's
running Windows 2000 I did Google if it
was Window XP but as we don't get those
luscious Green Hills in Blue Sky and and
just this plain blue background that's
Windows 2008 we've got that right at
least now he says not today you knew
World Order Jack Boots and it seems like
he might even be a conspiracy theorist
that thinks the governments unleash the
cordyceps we've of course just lived
through something similar and every time
I logged into Facebook in 2020 and 2021
my uncle he was saying something like
this now we see him basically doing a
Tony Stark and Welding away he wishes
when a trap is sprung and we meet Frank
if you watch the White Lotus then you
probably instantly recognize this guy
and this is Murray Bartlett who plays
Armin in that show now I also think that
casting Nick Offerman is genius and he
suits being Bell down to a t the guy
looks exactly like how he does in the
game and they even have a belt of
shotgun bullets that he wears over his
shoulder bill is one of the most
interesting characters in the first game
but we actually learn very little about
him he's very much a closed buck and in
some ways he does mirror Joel both end
up looking after someone that they
initially don't want to and they see
just how heartbreaking that can be now
intercut with this is shots of Bill
eating on his own we catch him pulling a
carrot out of a garden and in the
background we can see a white church
this is potentially where he's held up
at and he's living a very solitary
lifestyle refusing to let people in and
this is what keeps him alive however he
clearly lets Frank be close to him and
the two are pretty much opposites to
each other that are gonna have to learn
to get along Frank is just a normal guy
or as Bill is a doomsday out that's
prepared for every eventuality so that
he can survive I think their
relationship is going to be fascinating
to watch and with the ladder being a
control freak it's going to be
interesting to see how the tension
between them plays out during this we
also see Ellie walking around the house
she's wearing the classic red t-shirt
that she had in the game and in a draw
she finds a gun in a ladder it's
possible that this letter was the one
left behind by Frank and this would
build upon what we talked about earlier
now the gun is also the one that she
uses throughout the game and it's based
on a Beretta 70 series originally she
didn't get this until much later on and
she picked it up at the hotel when Joel
was being attacked Joe had forbidden her
from having weapons but after she saved
his life he decided to trust her more
now we then go to jail warning bill that
Raiders will be there soon in the game
he said that he'd never actually been to
Lincoln himself and going out there with
Ali was an act of desperation this was
because of Tessa's death but it seems
like she's coming back as we can
actually see her in the background
standing around with Frank by she's
coming back I mean Ana tour of the
actresses and this is obviously going to
be a flashback kind of showing how they
met over the years I'm guessing that
they'll pop up throughout the episode
showing them meetings and they of course
had this whole thing with the radio set
up in episode one so we'll probably see
something along those lines now this
prediction of the writers comes to pass
and we see people attempting to swarm
the fences Bill's trap sets off and it
burns them but it seems like something
bad goes down and he ends up telling
Frank to call Joel episode one of course
ended with 80s music playing on the
radio and this signified danger now from
here we go to Joel and Ellie on the road
probably making their way out to him
they pass some corpses in the road and
you'd often stumble across these when
you are making your way through the game
one of them looks like a kid and it
shows just how dangerous that the world
is now now from here we get a shot of a
truck ramming through a fence and we
know from the other scenes of the
trailer that this is Bill driving this
you also see Ellie opening up her knife
and moving it near one of the infected's
heads this is a stalker that has started
to go blind and he's on his way to
becoming a clicker due to the fungus
growing out of his eye with Ellie
crouching down here I'm guessing this
guy's on the floor somewhere and he
might be stuck in one of Bill's traps I
was thinking for a second that he might
not actually be attacking Ali due to her
already being infected but this would
kind of break the rules of the game the
clicker in episode two of course
attacked her and there was that one that
gave Tess the kiss of death so I doubt
that they're they're that aware that
they won't just attack someone if
they've already been infected anyway I
think it's probably in a build trap that
they come across at some point in the
episode now the trailer ends with bell
reassuring gel that they'll be fine but
whether this is true or not remains to
be seen he looks pretty out of it when
he tells Frank to contact Joe and I
think he'd only do this in dire
circumstances now Lincoln was a part of
the game where you never actually fought
against any humans it was swarming with
infected but as for Raiders and the like
these were completely absent therefore
Belle might not have been as prepared
for this and this is why he ends up
getting Frank to get Joel the radio
message at the end of episode 1 also
teases that and then of course love to
hear your thoughts and theories for the
episode next week anyway huge thank you
for watching the video hope you enjoyed
it like to apologize for calling the
infection a virus in episode 2 breakdown
everyone's going a bit angry and you
know I'm really sorry I hate making
mistakes like that especially because
I've got to go back I wish I could fix
it uh so yeah thanks to everyone who
corrected me on that and uh I hope you
enjoy the rest of your week we are in
competition right now as well and giving
away wakanda forever to three
subscribers on the 15th of February and
all you have to do to be with a chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode repeat the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so that to you then message me
on Twitter at heavy spoilers if you
haven't watched our episode 2 breakdown
and that'll be linked on screen right
now hopefully I'll see you over there
right after this just ignore the virus
remarks anyway without the wait thanks
for sticking through the video I'll see
you next time take care peace